great story great guy great player
i think that we don't and maybe we'll
need some time to understand that alex
smith
was one of the better quarterbacks of
his era he had some incredible seasons
he had some incredible postseason
performances never got to the top of the
mountain never was the best quarterback
in the game never was one of the best 10
maybe one of the best five at times he
was in that fringe but we always kind of
forgot him and then he had the serious
injury and he'll always be known
not just for the injury but for coming
back from it and playing last year and
giving aaron donald a ride with the full
weight of donald on his back testing out
that surgically repaired like with all
the infections and the procedures and
could have died not could have just lost
his leg could have died so an amazing
run
and
i i thought he he'd end up with someone
this year miles and like so many other
great quarterbacks who've achieved at a
high level i'm anxious to see what he
does moving forward because i'm i'm i'm
betting on him being a success or
whatever he chooses to do
uh no doubt about it and you know i i
think that some people my friends uh
maybe would classify me and describe me
as maybe a cold callous person but i got
to tell you mike like watching that
video for his retirement and seeing all
the things that he went through again
you know and all that rehab process and
maybe a little bit emotional and him
talking about his wife and going on
those walks with his wife and you know
having the kids in the backyard and they
got no idea what's coming i just i think
it's a really really amazing awesome
wonderful story that alex smith was able
to get back to playing as a starting
quarterback and also leading a team to
the playoffs i mean yes they were seven
and nine with washington last year but
they still were able to make it to the
playoffs in large part because of his
performance so i just think it's an
awesome story and the fact that he got
to go out on his terms not because of
the injury i think that makes it even
better so yeah
happy trails to alex smith i'm also
really looking forward to seeing
whatever he does next
i have a very important question for you
miles prompted by your most recent
remarks are you ready for it
uh-oh were you a cold callous person
before or after
you joined us at pft no oh much before
it's probably why you wanted me to join
pfd if you're being completely honest
mike
yeah i've always been an alex smith fan
and it seems like he's always fought
through some degree of adversity and the
injury and the way that he handled
himself after that made me respect him
even more and i'm kind of glad he's not
going to play again i've said this
before when i watch him play i was
telling rich eisen this earlier today on
his show i felt like i was watching my
son play high school football where
every play every snap every contact
you're holding your breath is he gonna
be okay don't suffer a serious injury is
he okay is he okay okay who on to the
next play that's how i felt watching
alex smith last year and i think that
stress probably complicated the extent
to which teams wanted to put him on a
football field remember he said
that washington didn't want him playing
last year it's not because he didn't
like him because they probably didn't
want to deal with that concern
is he truly okay is he suited to play
after everything he's been through and
he proved to all of us that he is and he
ended up being the best quarterback that
the team had last year they ended up in
the playoffs yes his run ended early
because of a calf problem but i really
thought it was impressive and he's
since said that
he considered signing with the jaguars
urban meyer wanted him in jacksonville
and i i think it's a combination of
other things you want to do
chances of actually playing
what they're compensating you to
continue your career because veteran
backup quarterback it's not a gigantic
paycheck when you've made almost 190
million in the nfl you really don't need
to chase the paycheck it's okay if you
do joe flacco is in that i'll take
whatever i can get to be on an nfl team
phase and that's his prerogative but for
alex smith
apparently his priority is
unless i'm going to play i just don't
want to do it and i think that's what it
came down to no one's going to give him
the keys to the car
he's going to just be an injury
replacement or
a none of the above option he doesn't
want to do that he's moving on like you
said he's leaving on his own terms and
not many guys get to do that
exactly and that's one of the great
things that i obviously think is about
it but i mean you're talking about him
maybe joining the jaguars and i think we
talked about this on the show mike look
he could have maybe been a darn good
mentor to somebody like trevor lawrence
and we've already seen him kind of take
on that role with somebody like patrick
mahomes before and mahomes spoke
glowingly about alex smith even today so
i just think that it's great to see that
he is able to leave on his own terms and
you know the fact that he was generating
some interest makes sense but i think he
just wasn't going to be a starting
quarterback at this point in his career
and if you're not going to be a starting
quarterback at this point in your career
then yeah like why why do i really want
to go and put my body in my mind and all
the stress everything make myself and my
family go through all that you know i
think that one of those things you were
bringing up about how you're holding
your breath every time alex smith went
out there ron rivera even talked about
that a little bit how he was thinking
about you know i'm gonna be the coach
that put alex smith back on the field if
something really bad happens to him in
some ways that's gonna fall back on me
and so i think that you know when you're
talking about a coach putting him out
there him going out there his family
thinking about him going out there
it probably lets everybody exhale a
little bit when they see that retirement
video and they just know you know what
he's leaving on his own terms it's done
he made it through that revolving door
of coaches and offensive coordinators in
san francisco to lead the team to the
nfc championship game in 2011. the
division round win over the saints an
awesome epic game it was one of those
moments and they don't happen very
frequently where you are consciously
aware that you are experiencing a great
game and i remember that there he goes
with that run i remember
saying during that game to myself as i'm
watching it alone
i remember exactly where i was
and i'm thinking not that i wasn't alone
by i was alone not by like nobody wanted
to be around me i just remember exactly
where i was thinking this is an awesome
game this is a historic game all right
but my point is this guy was awesome in
that game the 49ers and alex smith
worked and it was the concussion in 2012
that opened the door for colin
kaepernick and uh even up until that
point alex smith was great and then he
goes to kansas city
and
the game against the colts where they
were up huge in the second half he had
an awesome game 30 for 46 378 yards four
touchdowns no interceptions in that game
that the colts came back and won 45-44
so he had his moments
and
never like i said never got to the top
of the mountain but was in the vicinity
enough that we should appreciate what he
did and uh to survive as much as he did
from teams to coaches to coordinators to
offense to this to that that is as
impressive as anything
in its own way as any quarterback has
done in the past generation
oh look you play 16 seasons and you
start as many games as alex smith did i
mean it doesn't matter where you're
drafted or anything that is an
impressive career and i think that most
players most quarterbacks even don't get
to where alex smith got in his career
and you know yes he didn't get to the
top of the mountain he didn't win a
super bowl but at the same time he was a
part of a lot of playoff teams you know
if you had alex smith you at least knew
you had a chance to win and there's so
many quarterbacks who were either
drafted that high or drafted lower and
become starters that don't always give
you that chance to win every single week
and i think that competitive nature and
everything that he was able to do
combined with the fact that he then came
back after that devastating leg injury i
think we do need to definitely give alex
smith as props
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports